she looks like she's just sleeping and
she's gonna wake up in the next minute
and you just want to ask her question
and I mean is it just a feeling that
she's really gonna come back and answer
your question it's been five years since
Court dolls last saw that don't say yeah
and I can see already that the dance
Asia has grown a little bit more saggy
than she used to be she is aging a
little less gracefully than the other
mummies that's probably because she's
also an older patient a study done on
hair cuttings buried with the girl
revealed that her hair was elaborately
braided just before she died perhaps as
part of the sacrificial ceremony let me
see if there's any hair that's it's time
to take a sample of the DOE say--is 500
year old hair Hey look this this is a
white hair look look look she had white
hair
it's census that's that's the dancing
yes here this is very unusual for a 15
year old to to have gray or white hair
is it's muy bizarre it can be due to
genetics I mean some young people do
have white hair and a very early age but
it can also be
to stress and that would be quite
interesting quartiles is not the only
scientist who has taken that don't say
as hare in 2003 a team of scientists
from the University of Bradford in
England sampled hair from all three
children it was analyzed for changes in
chemical signatures of elements like
carbon nitrogen and oxygen
a detailed timeline surfaced about what
these children ate and how they lived
from her hair the team discovered a
countdown to sacrifice that began months
before her death
and the first event was one year before
the death of the maiden as shift from a
diet of vegetables and potatoes was
changed to the food of the elite maize
and animal protein
in only a moment her life changed
forever
the scientists believe that the maiden
was being fortified for her destiny on
top of the volcano
[Music]